[Applause]
[Music]
kevin you said that 20 of your
investments are in crypto and so i just
want to start with what are you doing
are you exiting some of these positions
are you buying more
no i'm actually averaging down on a
couple of the big market cap names i
mean one of the challenges and this is
this is proof now for why we need
legislation and policy on crypto because
if we had institutional capital coming
in under the market if they had
allocated 50 basis points or 100 basis
points to let's say ethereum or bitcoin
salon or polygon whatever you would have
had a bid instead because we're
basically
under owned by institutions we have
tremendous volatility
and we've seen this before this is not
new um it'll you know recover eventually
but this is the nature of crypto
unregulated and so my argument is this
really should get us focused on policy
right after the midterms i'm hoping for
policy on stable coins and then
into other assets as well nfts that kind
of thing we're at the nasa stage but the
volatility is because we don't have the
institutional bid i do want to talk more
about policy in just a moment but before
that how should retail investors be
thinking about this sell-off is it an
opportunity to buy at a discount or is
it just too risky to make any sort of
bet at the moment
no i mean everybody has challenges with
volatility but i remind everybody just
go back 17 years to a stock called
amazon
it also corrected 38 to 50
every year for 12 years in a row as
people tried to figure out what this new
entity was and so there's always
tremendous volatility in new and nascent
technologies and new markets and crypto
is a new market i still predict in 12
minutes 10 or 12 years it'll be the 12th
sector of the s p there's just too much
productivity opportunity here around
payment systems and all kinds of other
attributes of these blockchain
projects that we just don't yet know
what the upside's going to be and i'd
argue this if you go to any graduating
class particularly now it's very timely
to say this ask any engineering cohort
you're going to find a third of the
engineers go into the chain they want to
work there they don't want to work in
the other 11 sectors of the economy they
want the opportunity to create something
new and that's why you've got so much
intellectual capital going into this
space you know with certainty down the
road that the next genius ideas are
going to come from this any college any
university any engineer they all want to
work on the chain
well on that last point
let's talk about crypto focused
businesses for a moment coinbase this
morning announcing that they're cutting
eighteen percent of their staff gemini
had a similar announcement as did
crypto.com microstrategy is down 75
year-to-date are crypto companies
uninvestable at this point
no i wouldn't say that there's there's
two categories of crypto companies ones
that use leverage
and ones that don't now when you have a
very volatile asset and you have
the
fortitude i'm going to use that word to
use leverage to enhance your returns you
also run the dark side downside risk of
what happens when there's a major
correction
as is occurring right now you can get
caught offside pretty quickly and so
celsius there's a good example of that
and i don't want this to sound trite but
let me explain what how bottoms are made
in any market i don't care if you're in
equities or in debt or in crypto or in
real estate
you always need a big player to go to
zero that always helps whether it's
long-term capital or whether it's
one of these crypto infrastructure
companies i would like to see and i
don't i don't want this to happen but it
always gives you a good bottom when you
get a large player over levered that
goes to zero and that always tends to be
the beginning of the rebuilding process
so if you have to sacrifice
someone who used too much leverage and
it's always leveraged it does this
somebody's over levered positions are
complicated they're not transparent
they're not liquid and they go to zero
someone is out there on the brink of
zero that's okay
in fact i'd argue that's a good thing
when we get it now do we get it this
week do we get it next week someone's
going to zero i don't know who
but it'll be great for everybody else
that survives because everybody will
learn from that and that's what i like
about a washout uh an event and i think
we're we're due for one in in crypto
land and i don't know who it's gonna be
but i guarantee you 100 i've seen this
movie before you will learn later that
somebody put on a heavily levered
position they got wiped out and it's
good it's a good thing
so to that point how are you navigating
this crypto winner for the crypto
businesses that you're involved in
i don't use leverage on crypto because
i've seen volatility like this in the
past there are certain assets where i
might put leverage on but it won't be in
crypto i mean when you see volatility of
50 on an 11-month basis which we're
seeing in bitcoin 60 20 days on ethereum
you can't afford to put leverage on that
but you know people will learn their
lessons this is a good thing in in in
the sense that this generation of crypto
investors has not gone through
corrections like this and not gone
through them with leverage now they're
going to learn an important lesson
everybody i know that has survived
volatility has had a very important
lesson or a date with leverage and they
didn't have a great dance that night i
must tell you are there any takeaways
for retail investors who are looking to
buy the dip and add to add to their
portfolio any categories of
cryptocurrencies they should be looking
at anything that they should be wary of
i think right now if you're you know
licking your wounds go to the large cap
projects i mean the ethereum bitcoin
obviously polygon solana uh thereon's
polygon's been slaughtered and it's a
good project great opportunity to add to
it
i have very big positions in these in
these names and i've been nibbling as
well there's nothing wrong the one thing
i would tell everybody is you can't
pick the bottom it's impossible you have
no idea when it's going to happen but if
you're if you're staying along the
category you need diversification i have
so many different positions on right now
and they're all over the map now come
year end what will happen because this
is a year where we're going to be
looking at tax returns on all crypto
trading and income there'll be a lot of
maneuvering on the projects that did not
recover to take them as tax losses
versus the ones that did and that's
going to be the nimbleness of trading
and that's why it's important to look at
your positions and make sure you have
liquidity in them because and most of
these projects are very very liquid so
it's not a problem and we have we
actually haven't seen we had the binance
story yesterday they looked for a couple
of hours of room on what they called a
lazy trade the celsius thing well that's
a gate
that's not good so um
that will not end
end well and when you lock the gate in a
hedge fund basically
you upset a lot of investors and they
when they get the opportunity to sell
they do with a vengeance never good to
do this can't help them but you know
they didn't understand the situation i
guess but
there'll be some money lost there but
finance is the big daddy of them all on
platforms and they seem to be surviving
ftx looks fine
circle rock solid didn't break a buck
put out an announcement to their
investors yesterday saying look we've to
the extent we've had to have margin
calls there hasn't been a problem you
mean these are the things you look for
it's stress situations you've got a lot
of infrastructure holding its own
so i think there has been some
maturation or maturity coming into the
crypto market by these behemoth
infrastructure projects i'll say the
same for bit by and for wonderful
uh holding their own making sure their
clients are being being taken care of i
have big positions in those companies as
well so we're all you know weathering
the storm
and uh you have to do this there's
nothing there's nothing else to do
except watch with wonder
now you said that it's hard to call a
bottom but let's say we continue to see
a sell-off is there the possibility that
the crypto sector uh you know dropping
in value could hurt the u.s economy
ultimately or is it just a degree of
magnitude so irrelevant that it it's not
going to make much of a difference
well the great news about the crypto
economy and even positions like bitcoin
or ethereum these are decentralized
holdings it's not just the american
investor exposed here bitcoin is all
around the world and it's only 880
billion before the correction which as
you rightly pointed out is a big nothing
burger and so that's nothing i mean you
know even all of crypto under 2 trillion
is still nothing in financial services
so there's so much upside to the sector
when we do get policy when we get
institutional investors and sovereign
wealth involved then you'll start to see
real assets but you know if bitcoin went
down another 20 it wouldn't really
matter because it's spread around
everywhere and and most of the holdings
are not institutional for all the
excitement about bitcoin no institutions
own it yet and that's the decision you
have to make at a time like this when
you're an investor i mean this is an
opportunity to say to myself or anybody
look if i believe in three years 36
months that this there'll be policy on
bitcoin do i want to own it after policy
comes and all the institutions start
buying it or do i want to take a chance
and live with some volatility now and
buy it here at 24 23 or 20 000 whatever
it's going to go to i don't know
but if you believe in bitcoin it's a
buying opportunity but you can't
guarantee that you're catching the
bottom nobody catches the bottom it
never works that way so let's return to
that question of policy
the crypto space is expecting to get
some clarity a lot of draft legislation
circling and washington what are your
thoughts on on some of the bills that
we're seeing put forward
well i've spent a lot of time on the
hill in the last two months i've met
with everybody that's
brought a bill forward hagerty toomey
lamas i mean there's a lot of interest
in this
here's what i think is going to happen
they're going to pick one thing
they're going to pick one thing and put
policy on that it's going to be stable
coin to start and the policy there is
going to be pretty clear all the bills
say the same thing they want total
transparency they want an audit every 30
days they want no duration more than 12
months on any asset holding up the coin
so that means t bills on average are
going to be seven eight month duration
and us dollars backing it and that's the
same kind of rule you're going to find
in a schwab money market or a fidelity
money market or any money market fund
with the benefit of all of these systems
once you put policy in place
having the ability to be a payment
system so i would love to see this
happen and the reason i think you'll get
policy makers on both sides of the
aisles backing this one thing
after the midterm elections is this
guarantees making the u.s dollar the
currency of default in perpetuity once
you back the us dollar on a stable coin
everybody's going to want to use it i'm
not going to use the chinese one i'm not
going to use the swiss franc i'd be
worried about liquidity i'm not going to
use the euro the euro is all over the
map i'm certainly not what want nothing
to do with russia and i'm not going to
use the british pound i want the u.s
dollar to be a payment system that
everybody else will accept around the
world like they do for commodities like
oil it's priced on the us dollar so if
we get stable coin policy you talk to
any policy maker about this they get the
joke in two seconds it's so simple to
understand this some of the issuers will
become fdic insured they'll be like a
bank
others will say no i don't want to be
fdic in short and we'll have a plethora
of different offerings all around the
same policy so i can choose maybe i'll
put some money into the fidelity one i'm
saying the same thing i do right now i
put dollars into the oppenheimer money
market i put money into schwab's money
market so the same thing will happen on
stable coins now we just have to wait
for policy and right now in usdc the one
that's holding the buck rock solid 54
billion in assets right through the week
right through the correction no problem
with liquidity i wrote more contracts
this week on it so look there's a lot of
people interested in making this work i
think we'll get policy there first if
you like that video wait you see my next
one don't forget to click right over
here and subscribe